This episode was proudly
made possible by Subaru.
So one of the ways
in which I describe
human beings is by saying
we are addicted to the new.
Now, what does this mean,
addicted to the new?
It means that we are
addicted to explore
the perimeters of possibility.
We are addicted to
probe the unknown,
to gnaw against the ineffable.
We are programmed neurologically
with the chemical dopamine
to reward us for overcoming
limitations and exploring
the unknown.
This idea, this
addiction to the new
is responsible for a species
that didn't stay in the caves,
didn't stay on the planet.
And it won't stay within
the limitations of biology.
Literally, we are
addicted to the new,
and that is why
we have triumphed
to become the chief
agents of evolution.
It's the dopamine.
Be sure to check out
Second Chance Subaru
at revision3.com/subaru.
[MUSIC PLAYING]